- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to Ed Talks.
You could view this as a flavor
of our homeroom live stream
that we focus more on education topics.
First of all, I wanna wish
everyone a happy new year.
Hopefully your 2021 is
already off to a good start.
And we have a really
exciting conversation today.
We actually have the leadership
from Khan Lab School here.
We're gonna talk about
that in a little bit
after I give my standard announcements,
but this is a school that I started
alongside several other folks
to really compliment
the work of Khan Academy
to show how a physical
environment can be liberated
if you're able to let students work
at their own time and
pace and master concepts.
We're gonna be talking a lot
about what we've learned
at Khan Lab School
over the last six or seven years
now that it's a K-12 school,
we're gonna be talking about
how we navigated COVID.
So if you have any
questions on any of that
feel free to put in questions
in on YouTube or on Facebook.
But before we begin that conversation,
I remind everyone that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about gonna
khanacademy.org/donate
and making a donation.
Also wanna give a special shout out
to several organizations that stepped up
really when COVID hit
when they realized that Khan Academy
was already running into deficit
and that deficit was growing
as we had to step up to
support more students.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis.
But I will remind everyone
that that's helped,
but we still need more help,
especially now that we're in 2021.
Sorry for that.
My local wifi isn't what it
(poor connection drowns out voice)
Wait, wait, I was in
the midst of introducing
the KLS leadership team,
Rachel Skiffer, Kim Dow.
Rachel is the head of the
school at Khan Lab School.
Kim Dow is the head os the
upper school at Khan Lab School.
Rachel and Kim, thanks
for joining us today.
- Thanks for having us.
- Hi, Sal. (chuckles)
- We all work very closely to each other.
(laughter drowns out speech)
Rachel, maybe a good place to start.
For those folks who aren't
familiar with Khan Lab School
you've been head of school
there for three years now.
Your previous role was a
head of strategic planning
at Phillips Andover.
When you first came to Khan Lab School,
and actually in the three-year since,
what's really stood out to you
as what differentiates the school
and what you think we have
the potential to do or show
for the broader community?
- So many things.
So one of the things
that stood out for me,
I think there's certainly
a national conversation
about what needs to change for students
to keep them engaged,
to make sure that access,
learning, everything is equitable.
And in particular,
there are some systems that
have been around for so long,
even when they want to change,
it's very difficult to do.
And so what stood out for me
and which still stands out
for me for Khan Lab School
is we are very thoughtful about what we do
and if there's something that's
working well, we amplify it,
and if there's something
that we need to switch up,
we're able to be incredibly nimble
and to be able to make those
changes really quickly.
So that I appreciate as an educator.
And I think particularly
being able to listen to our students
and take that feedback
in and our teachers.
I love the true lab piece of the school
in that every part of the
community is in it together
and we have the same goal
of not only making Khan Lab
School, or KLS as we call it
as strong as possible,
but I think that mission,
that what we're doing here
is really for us to share out
for the benefit of schools and educators
and students everywhere.
- And when the school was
started, there were some theories,
some founding principles
that we wanted to test as a lab school,
this idea that learning
doesn't have to be bound
by time or space,
that students should be
able to learn concepts
at their own time and pace
that they should be able to show mastery,
that if you get 80%,
you shouldn't just get a C
marked on your permanent
transcript or your forehead
for the rest of your life,
that you should get an
opportunity to get that mastery
that'll set you up better
for more advanced things
and it gives everyone as multiple chances,
but there's been other ideas
around full year schooling,
full day schooling, having
students teach each other,
there's, everyone's a
student, everyone's a teacher,
that's what the shirts
say at Khan Lab School.
How do you feel about those things?
What do you think the school
has been able to prove out
that are working well
and where do you think we
could push even harder?
- I think it shouldn't
be a radical notion,
but the part you mentioned
about every student can
achieve at a high level,
I think that mastery piece
is incredibly important.
There's so many other things
that kids do where they're
given the time to master it,
whether it's piano,
whether they're a soccer
player or a dancer,
but for some reason when it
comes to science or math,
we're in these systems where
it's like, okay, move along.
So that notion that actually at our school
we don't have letter grades,
but for us mastery student
reaches 90% proficiency.
And so the mastery is constant,
the time at which that happens changes.
And so that's incredible to me
and incredibly motivating for students,
even the ones where it takes
them a little more time,
because there's not this
fear of failure is one thing,
but I think also
internally then the notion
that people believe that they
can achieve at a high level,
that's incredibly profound.
And then I think as we've learned
through COVID and the pandemic
and everything that's
happening with schools,
we're built as a school
for parents who work.
And so the fact that we
can stay open until six
and have a program that's really enriching
after sort of traditional school hours
for those students who wanna stay
and so that parents can finish up
if they do have a job
that happens to end late in the afternoon,
I think that's a great building block
of how you even think about
a school in the community
beyond the academic piece.
- And one of the ideas
that a lot of folks have,
they think okay, Khan
Academy is definitely,
it's an online learning tool,
obviously KLS leverages
Khan Academy a lot,
but they might have a stereotype
where I would just describe
it as a misconception that,
oh, therefore this must be like
a super tech focused school.
Obviously it's a very tech savvy school.
It leverages online tools.
But Rachel, I've actually
loved Kim's thoughts,
especially as we go into high school,
but Rachel what would surprise people
when they visit the school
about the level of human interactivity?
- Sure, I think I always shock people
by letting them know that
we still teach cursive.
And the fact that there's great research
about sort of brain connectivity
and the ability to master material.
So for us, the tech is not
the point, it's just a tool.
And I think people would also be surprised
by how adept students are with
that piece of the learning,
particularly when we had
to do remote learning
in a few weeks.
So our students, when they got home,
they were used to going online,
using Khan Academy, being
able to show their teachers
by inputting things that they
they'd mastered something.
Sort of the, we talk a lot
about executive function,
executive skills at Kan Lab school.
So that's part of what built in.
And as you say often and in your book
that I think in general,
people don't give young folks
as much credit as they should
about what they're able to do.
And so just given where
we are in the 21st century
for students to have that ability,
but also they're reading books,
they're spending time with teachers,
they're really thoughtful
about how many hours they spend
in front of the screen.
And collaboration that's even in Zoom
our students are able to do it,
but I think when you come to campus
and see how much interaction there is
and how much time they
spend with each other
in addition to some of the
time that they spend on tools,
I think it just speaks
to the notion of how important
relationships are in schools
and for a teacher and student connection,
how that really helps build up a student
as they're going through
their journey of learning
from kindergarten
all the way through
the end of high school.
- And I could say I'm obviously involved
at the leadership level of the school,
but as a parent of three
students who attend the school,
one of the things that I hoped
and I couldn't have imagined
when I wrote "One World Schoolhouse,"
but I think the school
is doing it in spades
is to your point, Rachel,
the kids are interacting with
each other and the faculty
in ways that are in a
very positive way unusual.
I've never seen a group of kids
more invested in each other,
willing to help each
other across age groups.
And they genuinely view the faculty
as some of their best friends.
Like my daughter was telling me
how much she's missing
her teacher or teachers
over the holiday break
which is really a special
thing about the community.
Kim, as a head of the upper school,
which includes the high school,
one of the things that we
often hear and I often hear is,
okay, Sal, you've got all
these avant-garde ideas.
They make a lot of sense intellectually
that kids should be
able to master concepts.
If they're at a C level, they
should keep working on it,
get to an A level, get to true mastery.
But I, as a parent am worried
about how the universities
will look at that.
What about college admissions?
How does KLS, I would say stack up?
Now where we have our
first graduates this year,
they've started applying to colleges,
they've taken your traditional
standardized tests,
how in your mind is KLS stacking up
in this interface with the
real world, so to speak?
- That's a great question.
And what's really fascinating
is that our students,
and I think it's partly
because of the kind of culture
that Rachel was speaking to
that we have at the school.
Our students are incredibly relaxed
about the kinds of things
that they're pursuing.
And many of them are really
doing passion projects
and internships and wonderful
things in the community
and really pushing the accelerator
on some of the things that
they're interested in studying
in their class.
But at the same time,
they do not feel like they
are in a pressure cooker.
And I think one of the things
that really came as a
surprise to me is that,
and the high school is much younger
than the rest of the elementary
and middle school program
is how remarkably well they did
when we gave them opportunities
to do these sort of external validation
of what our program looked like
when they were doing things
like either taking dual enrollment classes
at local colleges
or taking standardized tests.
They didn't feel pressured
about getting exceptional results.
And then when we found out how they did
it was really quite remarkable
that they were stacking
up really quite well
against their peers.
So that's been a great surprise.
- It's probably considered tacky
to show off for your own kids,
but I think it's fair for me to show off
for other people's kids.
But you're exactly right.
I mean, I think this
graduating class what I've seen
is they're performing exceptionally.
I would say the average scores,
even though, as you
mentioned, the school isn't...
People believe that the
pressure cooker environment
is a necessity for kids to perform well,
especially in a lot of
places like Silicon Valley,
where everyone has these
very high expectations
for themselves or for their own children.
But I think what you and
the team at Kahn lab school
in conjunction with the
students have really shown is
there's a way for kids to have
a very healthy adolescence,
And at the same time,
be quite aspirational.
We have students who are
interning at startups,
self-driving car companies at NASA,
in some cases they're leading
college student interns,
they're performing on
traditional standardized tests.
Their average scores
are better than many highly
selective universities.
And that's in a context
where the school isn't saying
we are a pressure cooker environment
where you have to do homework all night.
It's more about, we believe
that you need the chance
to master concepts.
And if you master it and
have strong foundations,
then when you go get
assessed in the world,
you're going to do just fine.
I think that's the other misconception.
It's not that we don't have grades.
In fact, mastery in many ways
as a higher level of rigor
than traditional grades.
Traditional grades, you get to B too bad.
Mastery says, no, everyone
needs to get to an A level.
So I'm curious for both of y'all,
maybe we'll start with Rachel.
It's been about,
in 2014, we started with
the PowerPoint presentation.
There was 30 kids
ages five through, I
think, 11 at the time.
The school is now a little
over 200 students, K-12,
we have our first graduates
of this coming year
and it looks like they're doing very well
on all of these benchmarks
that Kim and I were just alluding to.
Rachel, where do you see
as the next phase of KLS
now that we've gotten this far?
- I think we have a few phases
I know that we're focused on,
I think it's one sort of
growth of the school, right?
So to be able to bring more kids in,
we had a great professional
development day as a team
really talking about diversity, equity,
inclusion, and justice.
And so I think that is a foundation
of the work we're doing here.
And so to be able to expand,
find space to bring more students in,
increased peer groups for teachers,
I think that's an important
step as a very young school
that has some really big
ideals and some big goals.
So I can let Kim chime in, but
that's one of the big pieces.
And I think continuing to share out.
If people want to go to our
website, khanlabschool.org,
there are some great blog posts
from teachers to other teachers
about some of the work that they're doing
around math and mastery-based learning,
how to use Khan Academy,
our students, even when they're on tools,
they're not by themselves,
that's group work,
and then they'll do some great
problem solving together,
project based learning.
And then also even
again, talking about executive skills
and what teachers,
and now in the pandemic,
what parents can do
to support their student's
autonomy of independence.
So just being able to broaden that
as a school with more students,
I think is really important
and more space to do that.
- Yeah, and what about you, Kim?
What are you excited about
now that you've rebuilt out
this incredible middle
and high school programs
that are seeming to really fulfill
a lot of what at least my
aspirations or dreams were
back actually even when one
world schoolhouse was written,
back in 2011, 2012.
Where do you see the next
phase for the upper school,
especially the high school?
- Well, we couldn't be more
excited in the high school
about feeling like we've really just begun
to hit our stride.
And as you said earlier, having
our first graduating class,
and one of the things
that we have really worked very hard on
in the last couple of years
is really deepening our partnerships
with local organizations.
And really in some unexpected ways,
it has really created some
wonderful opportunities
for the school, for our
students and for our teachers,
who especially I would say in the pandemic
really became really quite
adept at online teaching.
And that really brought
us back full circle
to really wanting to extend our reach.
And in many ways sometimes
we say we're a private
school with a public purpose.
But what does that really mean
for us in the high school?
And so in the coming years,
I really see us extending our partnership
with local colleges
and thinking about what
pre-college programs mean
for our students and perhaps
for our wider student body,
and thinking about more deeply
what does it mean to extend our reach
in terms of some of the
things that we've learned
in terms of offering online courses
and potentially online
programs to other students
out of our area?
So that's something
that we're thinking
very intentionally about
and whether that's something that we feel
that we can do well.
- Yeah, I mean, on both those points,
one thing that we've talked about,
which I think is fascinating
is this line between
high school and college
is really an arbitrary one.
And we know that just as everyone
should be able to fill in their gaps,
part of personalization is
if someone is ready for
college level material,
and sometimes we know the
students are quite young
who are ready for it,
there's no reason why they
shouldn't be able to do it
and get credit.
So maybe there's ways
that by the time someone
finishes high school,
they have two, three, maybe four years
of college credit one day,
which is going to be really
interesting to explore.
And ideally some of it, or
most of it can be in person,
but maybe there's ways
to give access to folks
who aren't able to be
present in the same way
which I could imagine
could be very exciting.
A lot of questions coming
in from social media,
from Facebook there's a question,
and this could be for both of y'all.
What does KLS do differently
from typical schools
to increase a student's independence?
So do they take more ownership
over their goals in life
and for their learning?
So how does that happen?
We both talked about it.
I could speak as a parent
and as a board member of the school.
I see it in spades, even when COVID hit,
even the young KLS kids,
didn't miss a beat.
They had their goals, they were
able to interface that way,
they were able to exercise
a lot of independence.
Rachel, and then Kim, what does KLS do?
How does this happen?
Is it just magic
or is it something that's
done very intentionally?
- It's both.
But no, I think the intentionality of it,
even with our youngest students,
so particularly starting in
second grade, third grade,
our teachers are also
advisors with a capital A.
And so they will spend
half an hour at least
with every student individually
and sort of coach them
in having a student set out
their own goals for the week.
So, okay, I wanna do some ELA work,
I wanna get some math done,
I wanna work on my passion project.
And so we actually give students
their own schedule with blink
spots for students to fill in
so they can really manage their work.
And so I think that's really important
for students to get that
practice very early.
And then the next week a
teacher will sit down and say,
so how did you do on your goals?
And if there was a goal
that a student reached
and maybe it was too easy for them to do,
we can help a student
push a little bit more.
And then if the goal is just unrealistic
and stressing out a student,
we can do that coaching.
So I think just having the practice
of being in charge of your work
and being really thoughtful
about what to do,
our kids know that,
oh maybe I should work on the
subject I like the least first
just to get that out of the way.
So that is a tool,
I think some adults don't
even really exercise
until it's too late.
So I think that piece is really important.
And then the second thing I'll add
is the self-paced piece
that you talked about.
And so our students really,
we talk about self
self-paced at a minimum pace,
but as they're thinking about their work
for the week or longer,
if they wanna set a goal
of finishing something
a little bit more quickly than
the standard say that's okay.
And then when it's time for
them to move to the next,
what would be a traditional grade level,
just in the subject,
we allow them to do that.
And so students don't
have to be bored, right?
And at the same time,
students have the ability
to go deeper in something
if they wanna do that.
So I think developmentally
it's nice for our students.
We have some fifth graders in
seventh grade standards math.
So they'll go to that math class,
but their home base is
still a group of students
that are within their sort of
age and developmental level.
So there's also that
safety social emotionally
of still being within an each peer group,
but being able to sort of spike class wise
if you need to do that.
- Yeah, that notion is super powerful.
As you mentioned, age is not a limiter
on students academic progression,
but the school does it very thoughtfully
because obviously there could be,
and we do have students
who might be fifth graders
reading at a high school or
even early college level,
but you have to be careful
of what they're reading.
But similarly, if there's a high,
and we have fifth graders, you mentioned
doing seventh, eighth, and ninth,
I think there's a few during
10th or 11th grade level work,
but they need to be supported,
make sure that they're smaller. (chuckles)
They can go into the environment
with the older students
and be in a position to thrive.
Kim, any thoughts on what do
you think KLS has been doing
either explicitly or implicitly
to allow students to
build that independence?
For some of these students
who at age 16 or 17
are walking into internships
and are managing college students
once again, how does that happen?
- Again, I think it's part
of the culture of the school
and it's really just part of the fabric
of the everyday experience
that students have,
especially with the relationships
that they're forming with their teachers.
And I think one of the things,
for example, at the
beginning of middle school,
students do a capstone project.
And so they really have
an opportunity early on
right before they begin high
school to do a deep dive.
And so they get the message early on
that there are no limits
to what they can ask to do.
And so as they enter
the high school program,
whether it's internships,
whether it is a capstone project
that they're doing at
the end of middle school
or at the end of their
high school experience,
or it's an independent study
that they or a group of
friends are proposing
or strong arming a teacher to teach,
they can really pursue
any topic at a deep level
within the environment of the school.
And one of the things that
really is fascinating.
We've gotten to a point
with our oldest students,
where they are now coming
to us and proposing classes
that they can teach to other students.
And so it's really come full circle
in the last couple of years.
- Can I add one more thing?
- Oh yeah, absolutely, Rachel.
- Sorry, the other thing
is we sometimes get
students who transfer in
who might in, maybe it's an
English language, arts or math
be a little behind and
we're able to catch them up.
And so depending they might
be a few months behind
of what would be expected for
a grade level or even a year.
And so our teachers are really thoughtful.
And again, with the belief
that all students can really
achieve at a high level
in mapping out with the
student and the family
sort of let's work together
to figure out how we're going to get you
to the school you have
of sort of being where you want to be
and think you wanna be.
And so I think that process
is also pretty unique to us
in that we're able to do
that pretty seamlessly.
And also I think with the
self-worth of the student
remaining intact.
- Yeah, and on that point,
I mean, we give the students
real responsibility.
We have upper school students
who are literally teaching
assistants or teachers
with real responsibility
of advanced math courses
as Kim just mentioned.
We have students
creating a linear algebra
course in linear algebra,
the college version,
the course is normally taken
in your sophomore or
junior year in college
as an advanced topic
is now a course that is
being created by KLS students
for other younger KLS students who are,
and then we've even had students
contribute to Khan Academy,
create our multi-variable
calculus course on Khan Academy,
which is now serving hundreds
of thousands of students
around the world
and that's normally the
type of responsibility
that you would give to someone with a PhD
and a lot of experience.
But we've been seeing some
really powerful things.
And to Rachel's point,
KLS does do a shadow day
to make sure students
are ready for the level of independence,
especially if they're coming
in as a transfer student,
but there isn't your traditional
IQ test or aptitude test.
And so we have had students come in
in the bottom quartile
in a certain subject
or the bottom a half,
and especially the longer that
they've stayed at the school,
especially by graduation,
almost all of them,
I think all of them are
operating in the the top decile,
if not a good bit higher than that,
which once again speaks to,
it's not just about
what a lot of times some
independent schools do,
we'll just cream the top and
then say, look what we did.
There's always a little
bit of that selection bias,
but I'd like to believe
that the mastery learning
and the ability to fill in gaps
and giving students real agency
and autonomy and opportunity
is playing a big role here.
There's a question here from Facebook.
Victoria Angelo Umedo,
how do you do mastery learning
or mastery based learning?
I need guidance for me
and my three elementary school children.
I can take a first stab
at it 'cause it's really,
Khan Lab School does it
all in in every subject.
Khan Academy is a big believer
in mastery based learning
in the subjects that it's able to cover,
but it's really just this notion
that if you, let's say in
math, get to an 80% level,
then you should get as
many attempts as possible
to get that to a hundred percent.
in a traditional model, you get to an 80%,
you're given a letter grade, given a C
and then you move on to the next subject,
that gap persists, those gaps accumulate,
and then you get to an algebra
class and nothing makes sense
'cause you have all these gaps
from fifth grade and sixth
grade and seventh grade.
Mastery based learning is
let's keep working on it,
identify, get an opportunity
to fill in your gaps,
and then ideally don't have
them in the first place
if you're at an 80% keep working on it.
And that's what the software,
the practice at Khan Academy does.
And then KLS is able to do that
in domains well beyond what
Khan Academy can offer.
It does that in writing,
it does that in humanities.
Speaking of that last point,
actually Kim, you've done
a lot of interesting work
with the group at Harvard
business school around civics.
I think that's another really cool example
of some of the innovation going on at KLS.
Tell us about the case-based civics course
that KLS has been doing.
- Again, it's just more about the power
of unexpected partnerships.
And we contacted the
Harvard Business School
and the Case Management Institute,
and one of our history teachers
developed this partnership with them
around taking a government
and politics class
which is a class that we
teach in our high school
and taking cases
that were being put
together by the institute
and using them as the
basis of this course.
And so it has actually
developed very quickly
into a partnership
whereby now this spring,
we have some external faculty members
who are in universities on the East coast
who are gonna start
coming and team-teaching,
and are interested in helping us
to further develop this content,
and again, extending it beyond KLS.
But again, I would say in the
humanities and in other areas,
there is a lot of power
in developing really high
quality high school content
outside of your institution.
And I would say our teachers
have really begun to push the boundaries,
not just in terms of
working with Khan Academy,
but also with working with
some other institutions
like Harvard Business School.
- And a lot of questions are coming in,
a question from Facebook, Tom Lowe,
are Khan Lab Schools going to be global?
From YouTube, Ibukhan Ekunwe,
KLS, do you admit people
living in Nigeria?
I could take a first stab at that.
So right now it's in the Bay Area.
I think there's some interesting things
to think about.
In normal years,
especially now that
it's a full K-12 school
we would probably have a handful of slots
primarily at the kindergarten
available every year.
There looks like there
might be an opportunity,
nothing's final for us to be
able to expand a good bit.
This coming year is almost an unusual year
where we might be able to expand.
So for people living in the Bay Area
that I think we're gonna be a
really interesting opportunity
right now.
And then we are exploring,
we haven't figured it all out yet,
ways to open up parts of the school
to someone anywhere in the world
if we can make the logistics
and the time zone workout
maybe there's ways to have
parts of these experience
available to the whole globe,
which is really what the
intention of KLS really is,
is to be able to serve everyone
and then also set an example
that other people can replicate and take
and make it useful for them.
In the time we have left
Rachel, any final thoughts
especially if there's
students out there listening,
some may be in the Bay Areas
who might be able to go to KLS,
maybe some outside of the Bay Area
who might wanna replicate this
type of thing for themselves,
or for parents,
or for people thinking
about starting the school,
what big messages or big
takeaways would you have for them?
And then I'll ask Kim the same question.
- Oh, that's a big question Sal.
I think for me in this moment
and what schools have had to do,
everyone is really sort of
yearning for a return to normal.
And I think sort of when
all of this is over,
it's really important for schools
and for families and students
who are seeking out schools
to think about,
is there anything in
this that we wanna keep?
And so in particular,
seeking out schools like Khan
Lab School, where for us,
the learning really is
centered with the student.
And also I think we're
spending a lot of family time,
but for us, because
there's all this research
that four hours of
homework in high school,
it doesn't make any sense.
Kindergartners should not have homework.
And so to think about
the culture of the school
and the support that
they provide your child
in really learning
and maximizing what
they're able to achieve,
and really allowing them
to think about what
they're passionate about
at a really young age,
and that that's not gonna be set in stone.
But I think what I love
most about Khan Lab School
is watching kids get really excited
about what they're able to do
and then to be able to share
and learn with other students.
And I think the other piece
is time is so important.
There are a lot of schools
where the more time as you said,
that kids spend stressed out and frazzled
somehow that is success.
And that's not the case at all.
I think we really are
mindful of what's important,
whether that's a strong
academic foundation,
being really thoughtful around
social, emotional learning
and how students work with other students,
and then also executive skills,
how students work with themselves
and that kind of discipline.
So for those who are in
the area and interested,
come check out Khan Lab School.
We have an open house on Saturday.
But I feel like when all of this is over
for us, it is a testament
to what we've already had in place
that's made some of the
transitions smoother
for our families than at other schools.
- Absolutely.
Kim, parting thoughts for folks listening
either in the Bay Area or outside it.
- I would say we have an
inquiry form on our website.
If you'd like to know more
in addition to the open
house that Rachel mentioned,
we have an inquiry form.
If you share your contact information,
we will be in touch with you.
And I would just share
that whether you are in a learning pod
or in a an online school
or in a school that has gone online,
whether you're a teacher or a parent,
don't forget that it's about the teaching
and it's about the pedagogy.
It's not about the platform
and don't be afraid to shake things up.
If there ever was a time,
this is a good time to do it.
And don't worry about going too fast.
Sometimes you have to go slow to speed up.
- Yeah, well, thank you both.
I get undue credit
oftentimes for Khan Academy
because I very humbly
put my last name on it.
And then the same thing
happened with Khan Lab School.
But all I can really say is
I set some of the vision
with a lot of question marks
and it's really being able to bring on
some incredible talent,
some leaders like yourselves,
who then brought on
really a world-class team
and I'm very proud of the
teachers and the whole community,
but especially the teachers we have at KLS
are just off the charts,
committed to what they do,
really the art of what they do
and the skill of what they do
that's really turning what
was a theory in a book
seven or eight years ago
into what I think is in a lot of ways,
a very interesting
lighthouse for education.
And I talk to a lot of heads of admissions
even college presidents,
and even though KLS
is still relatively small
by school standards,
a lot of people are taking a look at it
because I think everyone
is feeling this pain
of stress, anxiety,
depression is going through the roof
for young people these days.
But at the same time academic outcomes
and the ability to feel engaged in society
and have skills, either
soft skills or hard skills,
we're not seeing that advanced as much
even though kids are stressed out.
And I think the two of y'all
with this incredible team
are paving a path to show
that this isn't a trade off.
You can have really happy and healthy kids
who also do exceptionally well
in terms of academic
skills, content knowledge,
collaboration, ability to lead.
So thank you for being part
of this journey with us all.
It's gonna be fun.
- Thanks Sal, my pleasure.
- Thank you Sal, bye.
- Well, thanks everyone
for joining our first,
I was gonna say homeroom,
but I guess homeroom Ed Talks
live stream of the year.
I'm glad y'all had a chance.
We had Rachel on many months ago
but I'm glad you had a chance
to meet both Rachel and Kim
on some of the really exciting things
of what's going on.
So if you're at all intrigued
whether you live outside of the Bay Area,
or you're in the Bay
Area, as Rachel mentioned,
I think there's a open house this weekend,
check out kls.org.
And as now that KLS is
more and more established
and is starting to have a
lot of powerful data points,
I'm going to work with the team
to have the school fulfill its mission
even more of sharing a lot with the world
so some of these practices can
become even more mainstream.
So with that, I hope everyone
is having a great 2021,
and I will see you at
the next live stream,
which might be a homeroom or an Ed Talk.
See you then.
(chimes ring)